let's bring in tom homan former ice
director under president trump tom thank
you for taking time on a saturday
will we add now to this problem the fact
that when i have been covering the
caravans there are migrants from all
over the world to include african
countries what is your reaction to the
news of this new variant and the problem
on the border
i think the bite administration needs to
take title 42 seriously now under trump
title 42 everybody was turned back
because of the pandemic in the entire
time in the four months uh president
trump had the title fourteen on his
command i think they released a total of
56 people in the united states because
it has significant medical concerns but
look right now 85 percent of family
units are being let in regardless of
title 42 all unaccompanied alien
children latin regardless of title 42
and many single adults who have issues
that have been released united states so
i think this is the time president biden
has already stopped traveling from
african nations you know for a fact 150
countries come to your southern border
now is the time to take title 42
seriously and stop people from coming
united states during this crisis and
interestingly tom the ban on travel from
those countries doesn't stop until
monday a very interesting time frame you
would think they would have done it
right away they did issue today this do
not travel to those countries but what
we have seen and i have documented is
the pipeline that goes from all places
across the world from south america
through that panamanian jungle all the
way through central america all the way
to our border
this comes as we hear the administration
may be trying to reinstate remain in
mexico now mexico has not agreed to that
i tweeted just about an hour ago the
fact that they said they're awaiting a
response from the u.s so my question to
you is
what will that do if they did do that
would it help and do you think they're
going to
they're going to do everything they can
in a slow roll they don't want this to
be successful remember when they're they
had to be sued to do this right i was a
part of that lawsuit i actually wrote an
after david for texas in that lawsuit
they're going to be in in when the when
the court found against him and says no
you must implement remain in mexico to
help secure the border what the buying
administration do they appeal that
decision to secure the border so look
they're not taking it seriously they're
going to slow roll it i i don't think
they're going to
have it at the level the trump
administration did i'm hearing rumors
from my sources inside that look like
maybe 200 removals a day due to remain
in mexico under
well
these things happen the the technical
challenges of uh live television will
work on getting tom back but
what tom was talking about there is this
sort of back and forth between whether
or not remain in mexico which has been
court ordered will be put in place and i
was telling tom about the fact that
mexico has not yet agreed to do it it's
a two-way street remain in mexico has to
be agreed on both sides now what it
would do is for all migrants that are
applying for asylum will have to wait in
mexican cities that includes tijuana
juarez and matamoros those cities
already on the mexican border are
bursting at the seams with migrants you
would be now adding a lot more people
mexico's main concern according to a
release yesterday is that they want the
united states to provide and give access
to medical care and vaccination against
covet 19. all of this coming at this
news of the omicron variant being
unleashed you're looking now at our
flight fox team there in la jolla and in
the conversations i have had in just the
last 24 hours with border patrol agents
there they're very concerned about this
and the lack of enforcement i think
we've got tom back time i want to come
back to you because you're just weighing
in on whether or not this remaining
mexico policy is going to be reinstated
and if it would help
i think they're going slow roll it i
think it's going to be a small fraction
what the trump administration did rumors
that i hear from my sources in the site
that looked at maybe up to 200 removals
a day and when you talk about six or
seven thousand arrests a day and only
removing two hundred that's gonna have a
very small impact if they did the way
trump did it it would have like trump it
was a game changer for for trump
administration it caused an 86 percent
decline in illegal immigration 35-year
low and most of it was because remain in
mexico program biden should take a page
of the trump handbook and implement the
same way he did it but they're not going
to do it that way
tom i think it really what we really
need to hit today is how concerned are
you
to see no change in the surge already
the october numbers double that of last
october november already passing last
november the surge continuing little
being done by the administration to stop
it
meeting with this new coveted variant
look it's more than immigration issue i
don't care what people's opinion is on
illegal immigration this has turned into
a public health issue because this covid
variant because of the opioids coming
across the fentanyl coming across over
killed
already killed a hundred thousand young
americans this year we're talking about
criminals morbid arrests of ten thousand
criminals how many of that four hundred
thousand got away for criminals and i
heard brandon judd last night talk about
their estimating six hundred thousand
got aways this year and on top of all
that it's a national security issue when
half of the border patrol is not on the
line because you're processing family
units that's when bad guys come across
that's when cartels have moved people
with known suspected terrorists can come
across the country bor borbato already
rested 14 on the fbi screening database
how many of that 400 000 were known
suspected terrorists this is a huge
issue for this nation it's a national
security issue
hey last question with just the 15
seconds we got left should we be hearing
from secretary my orchestra about this
secretary of mayor is every time he
opens his mouth he's lying to the
american people that that he's an
embarrassment to the position he holds
he still says the board is secure he
still says the borders closed tell me
1.7 million entrants and 400 000 got
aways
and they had 600 000 releases they chose
to release 600 000 people in this
country that's not a secured border
that's an open borders and this is their
design this isn't mismanagement this is
an incompetence this is their plan open
borders and they're not going to attempt
to secure it former ice director tom
homan tom thanks for taking time